detrás mío se encuentra el enorme
socavón de la municipalidad de
Villanueva al que cayeron dos autos y
una moto el pasado 24 de septiembre
cuando se resquebrajó el pavimento
descubriendo una caverna que se calcula
mide entre 30 metros de largo y 15
metros de profundidad de allí se
encuentran atrapadas Olga Emilia Shoes
de 38 años y su hija Ellen Mejía shows
de 15 años quienes Se presume están sin
vida tras la imposibilidad de los
socorristas de dar con su paradero pues
las autoridades en este momento estamos
esperando máquinas especialistas para
poder hacer una rampa y poder rescatar
en nuestra familia porque ya se encontró
el el el lugar donde están solamente que
ellos están a profundidad de 15 metros
de profundidad de tierra hay agua
humedad y hasta abajo está la tierra y
abajo de eso están nuestros familiares
Guatemala rechazó la ayuda Internacional
de México para la búsqueda de las
víctimas pero desde el nororiente del
país tuvo que traer una maquinaria
especializada para detectar el vehículo
donde se encuentran presuntamente las
dos víctimas pero en este momento toda
la maquinaria se encuentra en completa
pausa se ha estado revisando
constantemente los estudios que están
realizando las instituciones para que
esto se lleve de la mejor manera posible
sin embargo Pues hay unos atrasos debido
primeramente al estado del tiempo del
clima que ha dificultado que se realice
lo más rápido posible en esta área
acordonada las diferentes autoridades no
han querido informar de Cuándo se estima
que se recuperen las dos víctimas madre
e hija sin embargo la información que se
tiene es que se construirá una rampa que
penetre el socavón algo que podría
llegar a tardar días con lo cual se
aspira no solo a recuperar a la madre y
a su hija sino también a descubrir otras
cavernas que actualmente representan un
riesgo inminente de otro desplome de
tierra en esta zona en la que confluyen
8 comercios y 50 viviendas